[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de l'actualité de la
semaine au Parlement et notre invité
cette semaine est Julien Bayou bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être sur le plateau de
parle-moi Hebdo vous êtes député
écologiste de Paris et membre de la
commission de la défense on a beaucoup
d'actualités pour vous cette semaine et
à la une cette semaine les violences
urbaines monopolisent les débats au
Parlement le gouvernement estime avoir
rétabli l'ordre républicain alors que la
gauche demande des réponses sociales
face à la crise et la droite exige des
mesures sécuritaires contre les
violences la ministre marine chappa dans
le viseur du Sénat la commission
d'enquête sur l'affaire du fond Marianne
dénonce dans son rapport la
responsabilité politique de Marlène
Schiappa dans la mauvaise gestion de ce
fonds gouvernemental sans ces lutter
contre la radicalisation en ligne mais
qui est suspectée d'avoir été mal
utilisé par certaines associations et
puis les députés examinent cette semaine
le projet de loi de programmation de la
justice un texte qui augmente les moyens
de l'institution judiciaire pour les
prochaines années
ce mardi à l'Assemblée nationale la
séance de questions au gouvernement
était donc très attendue après une
semaine de violence et de pillage qui
ont embrasé la France la quasi
intégralité des questions d'actualité
ont porté sur les émeutes avec comme
question la réponse sociale la réponse
pénale regardez ce compte rendu de
séance réalisé par Stéphanie Despierres
deux heures durant Elisabeth borne est
sur le grill toutes les questions
gouvernement sauf deux portent sur les
émeutes c'est la France insoumise qui
ouvre les débats pour réclamer une
réforme de la police comment un jeune de
17 ans peut-il être tué par un policier
en République française pourquoi 16
personnes ont-elles trouvé la mort
depuis un an et demi en France pour
refus d'obtempérer quand l'Allemagne
n'en compte qu'à mort en disant et le
plus glaçant combien de Naëlle n'ont pas
été filmées le retour au calme ne se déc
rète pas se construit vous vous cherchez
des coupables partout dans toutes nos
institutions républicaines sauf chez les
auteurs de violence
alors madame la Présidente panneau quand
vos députés rejettent tout appels au
calme vous sortez du champ républicain
quand une de vos députés affirment que
la fin justifie les moyens vous sortez
du champ républicain la première
ministre accuse les insoumis
d'instrumentaliser la mort de Naël les
républicains eux appellent à sanctionner
les parents des émeutiers quand on
laisse un gamin de 14 ou 15 ans dehors à
deux heures du matin par une nuit
d'émeute on doit avoir responsabilité
engagée c'est la loi appliquez-la pour
le rassemblement national Marine Le Pen
dénonce le chaos sécuritaire
qu'avez-vous fait de la France vous qui
menez la même politique que vous
prédécesseurs depuis 40 ans au moment où
vous vous apprêtez à nous resservir à
coup de milliard à énième plan banlieue
je vous appelle au courage de
l'autocritique il faut d'abord et avant
tout stopper l'immigration anarchique
vous démontrez une fois de plus la seule
chose dont vous êtes capable c'est la
caricature et vous voyez madame la
Présidente je regrette même si ça ne me
surprend pas beaucoup que le choix que
vous faites c'est celui de la division
et quand notre République est attaqué
c'est l'unité nationale qui doit
l'emporter je vous remercie l'assemblée
va continuer de se pencher sur ses
violences urbaines Gérald Darmanin sera
auditionné mercredi par la commission
des lois
Julien Bayeux est-ce que pour vous
l'exécutif a bien gérer cette crise pour
tenter de rétablir le calme et l'ordre
écoutez à revoir votre reportage j'ai
l'impression que c'est ni l'exécutif ni
le législatif et je m'inscris dedans ont
bien géré cette crise le spectacle donné
version en fait dans la caricature la
schématisation et je trouve que moi je
me suis peu exprimé jusqu'ici j'ai
beaucoup lu j'ai discuté avec des mères
qui était sur le terrain qui qui tenait
leur mairie littéralement
et dire que une personne qui peut vous
dire il y a une réponse une seule sans
nuance à la question vraiment je crois
fait du tort au pays en fait donc vous
avez préféré prendre du recul plutôt que
de oui parce que d'avoir des
déclarations que vous aurez pu regretter
comme on peut le faire certains de vos
collègues c'est peut-être arrivé oui
parce que à chaud et puis voilà
l'émotion était forte qui n'a pas pu
être ému face à ce crime c'est cette
homicide c'est assassinat du jeune Naël
par un policier qui devra répondre de
ses actes et qui n'a pas été en colère
devant ses pillages absolument
justifiable et dire que c'était soit
l'un soit l'autre dire que il y aurait
forcément des camps auxquel il faudrait
se rattacher alors que malheureusement
ou heureusement la réalité est
infiniment plus nuancée aujourd'hui vous
avez des personnes dans les quartiers
populaires qui pleurent leurs services
publics qui n'ont pas désormais de bus
ou de de voitures pour aller travailler
et qui vont avoir des difficultés à
graver vous voyez tout autour envoyer à
l'écart de ces populaires sont dans les
meute ou au contraire
tout le monde se tout s'est bien passé
circulait rien à voir parce qu'on l'a
aussi entendu
m'inquiète en fait en vérité parce que
si on prend pas le moment de post
sidération de réflexion et comprend pas
cette énième alerte au sérieux alors on
a un vrai problème parce que le le pays
se désagrégeait dans ce cas-là on va
évoquer les différentes réponses à
apporter à cette crise mais d'abord une
question politique Julien Bayou les
insoumis notamment Jean-Luc Mélenchon
n'ont pas appelé au calme dès le début
de ses émeutes est-ce que ça a été une
faute et moi je veux pas rentrer dans
dans la polémique permanente le
la justice exige du calme évidemment
mais voyez que moi j'ai vu beaucoup
d'interviews de mer qui rendait compte
de la situation et en leur disait
positionnez vous par rapport à un tel ou
un tel et pendant ce temps-là on n'avait
pas leur questionnement profond
c'est-à-dire comment la mairie est pas
brûlée demain comment des jeunes
professeurs qui arrivent très peu formé
parce qu'on
sent quelque part punis entre guillemets
comme ils sont peu formés ils commencent
par des quartiers plus difficiles avec
plus d'élèves par classe et
désespérés finissent par s'en aller et
du coup les classes se sont sans
professeur et c'est la même chose pour
les policiers et voyez si la polémique
empêche de poser ces questions et
peut-être de commencer à y répondre je
trouve qu'il y a un sujet est par
exemple dans les questions que pose la
France insoumise mais que je pose
également et
la mort de Naël on ne peut pas dire
circuler rien à voir unité nationale et
ceci cela
la question est posée il y a eu 13 morts
l'année dernière par refus de tempérer
ou suite un refus de tempérer un dans
les 10 dernières années en Allemagne 13
l'année dernière combien n'ont pas été
filmés
si aujourd'hui le ministre de
l'Intérieur ne nous dit pas par Edgar
pour la police républicaine et parce que
nous sommes attachés à la police
républicaine on doit faire le ménage
alors il y a un problème
ça change la donne on voit bien l'impact
de cette de cette vidéo diffusée
massivement relayée et qui a permis
le choc de la vidéo le drame tout le
monde mesure bien qu'on est pas égal
face à un contrôle policier je le mesure
chaque jour quand je me déplace
que ça me dégénère pas forcément autant
selon les quartiers selon le niveau
d'expérience des policiers ça joue aussi
beaucoup quand on a réduit la formation
des policiers et en fait on leur a pas
rendu service
on déplore le la perte de cette police
de proximité alors si les gouvernements
successifs veulent pas la remettre pour
pas avoir le sentiment de se déjger
changeons le nom mais en fait on a
besoin d'une police au contact des
quartiers et puis il y a un non dit je
profite que j'ai un peu de temps vous
voyez mais parce que sur BFM vous pouvez
pas
le trafic de stupéfiant
empêche une police de proximité empêche
même aux pompiers d'intervenir des fois
parce que vous avez des personnes qui
tiennent le four comme on dit à quand la
légalisation quand est-ce qu'on mesure
ensemble que non seulement ça pose des
problèmes de sécurité je pense que j'ai
pas besoin de développer mais surtout le
santé publique donc l'égalisation du
cannabis l'égalisation du cannabis on a
une des politiques les plus répressives
ou en tout cas mesurer qu'un débat vous
voyez je veux pas arriver avec des
solutions toutes faites et ça ne serait
de toute manière qu'une partie de la
solution mais quand est-ce qu'on peut
poser sérieusement le débat d'une
politique pénale la plus répressive en
Europe parmi les plus répressives et du
taux d'addiction chez les mineurs le
plus élevé vous voyez si vous la
légalisation du cannabis ça peut être
une solution pour rétablir un calme dans
les banlieues certainement pas la seule
certainement pas la seule mais il
n'empêche que ça peut mettre fin à des
trafics qui sont quand même installés
dans des cités ou les policiers c'est la
santé publique le cannabis est dangereux
pour les adolescents en particulier
le cerveau se développe il y a un
phénomène d'addiction qui est
indubitable il se trouve que la
prohibition est un échec voilà et par
ailleurs ça plein d'effets négatifs
corollaire sur la sécurité et même sur
la surpopulation carcérale
je relisais il y a pas longtemps on
l'appelle de Grigny et c'est mer qui de
banlieue qui il y a quelques années
disait au secours on nous enlève les
emplois aidés alors il y a eu tout un
sujet sur les employés un sujet
idéologique mais Jean-Luc Borloo les
appelle les emplois aidants vous voyez
c'était du soutien scolaire c'était un
appui à la mairie ou aux associations ça
fait cinq six ans qu'ils ont disparu et
ce qu'on n'est pas en train d'en payer
le prix avec la situation actuelle
Julien Bayon va évoquer le profil de ces
émeutiers qui sont très jeunes
d'ailleurs ce profil a été décrypté par
le ministre l'intérieur Gérald Darmanin
qui était auditionné au Sénat cette
semaine sociologique ininterroge la
sociologie des délinquants des imbé
interrogent sur ces 3500 interpellations
j'ai l'occasion de le dire la moyenne
d'âge entre 17 et 18 ans comme j'ai dit
tout à l'heure à ma connaissance 60% des
personnes que nous avons interpellé
n'ont pas de casier judiciaire et ne
sont pas connus des services de police
Julien Bayou est-ce que la solution à ce
phénomène à ce profil sociologique avec
des émeutiers très jeunes c'est de
d'abord rétablir l'autorité parentale et
comme et bien il réfléchit Emmanuel
Macron de sanctionner financièrement les
parents de ses métiers
ça me semble vraiment relevés du slogan
vous voyez j'évoquais juste avant
l'appel de Grigny qui était resté
lettres morte et qui se posait la
question
allons un peu en profondeur
des familles monoportentales
les maires isolées ils ont les mots
après un divorce une séparation et qui
se retrouve en général avec la garde des
enfants
pour vivre avec un loyer qui augmente
avec des dépenses de santé de nourriture
elles doivent travailler je crois que
c'est tout le monde le comprend les
femmes sont plus souvent victimes de
travail précaires de travail à temps
partiel contraint dans ces situations là
ça veut dire quoi sanctionner une mère
isolée qui travaille le soir ou la nuit
avec des fois des trajets de transport
très long parce qu'elle n'a pas pu
payer quelqu'un pour surveiller l'enfant
vous voyez donc moi je veux bien les
slogans tout ça enfin personne n'y croit
vraiment je vais ça veut dire quoi c'est
une double peine ça veut dire que parce
que elle n'a pas
pu payer nounou on va dire ça ou
quelqu'un qui garde à la maison parce
que il y a déjà des difficultés dans le
quartier on va leur mettre la tête sous
l'eau de plus vous voyez l'autorité
parentale c'est pour moi c'est du slogan
c'est à dire que et dont accompagnons
c'était le sens de ces emplois aidés les
employés c'était du soutien scolaire par
exemple là oui vous dites que la
répression n'est pas la bonne réponse
comment vous faites pour empêcher un
jeune parfois 12 mai jusqu'à 11 ans de
sortir la nuit avec des cocktails
Molotov pour aller attaquer à des écoles
quel est la bonne réponse
je vous dis déjà la personne qui vient
avec une seule réponse
je pense que ces emplois étaient le plan
Borlo alors il y a une chronologie
suppression des emplois aidés appellent
de Grigny qui a débouché sur ce plan
Borloo qui à la poubelle par le
président
le sous-titre c'était pour un plan de
réconciliation nationale il y avait
notamment
des adultes relais correspondant de nuit
il y avait la question des services
publics au cœur des
îlots il y avait la question des mamans
de la République la formation pour ces
merisoler et autres donc réponse très
globale qui qui n'exclut pas le
sanctionner quand il y a un dérapage
évidemment mais une réponse beaucoup
plus globale je pense aussi on peut
s'interroger sur
les phénomènes de d'émulation ou de
entre jeunes garçons
on a vu peu de filles pas pour dire
qu'il y en avait pas mais on a vu peu de
filles ces jeunes garçons
en phénomène de bande ce sont montés la
tête ça doit interroger c'est plus de
l'ordre culturelle à ce moment là il
faut notamment regarder toutes les
mesures qui étaient proposées dans le
plan Borlo et oui alors
ce contexte Bou illant il y a une loi de
programmation qui est examinée à la
justice à l'Assemblée nationale pardon
pour donner plus de moyens la justice
dix mille postes supplémentaires dont
1500 de magistrats d'ici à 2027
explication de texte à la tribune avec
du pour mon Eric Dupond-Moretti
je suis venu vous présenter les lois de
programmation et de réforme du statut de
la magistrature les plus ambitieuses de
l'histoire du ministère de la Justice
comme je l'avais dit lors de ma prise de
fonction je suis venu avec vous
tournez la page des mauvaises habitudes
qui gangrène notre justice depuis de
trop nombreuses années l'un des
objectifs est clair il est ambitieux
divisé par deux l'ensemble des délais de
justice d'ici
Julien Bayou le gouvernement veut donc
améliorer fortement les moyens de la
justice est-ce que pour vous c'est
nécessaire c'est important c'est crucial
si vous n'avez pas accès à la justice
vous n'êtes pas véritablement un citoyen
c'est le cœur c'est le pouvoir avoir
accès à la justice et faire valoir vos
droits vous obtiendrez rien de cause
vous n’obtiendrez pas gain de cause
c'est le juge qui tranche mais la
possibilité d'accès au juge est
absolument cruciale et ça fait partie
d'ailleurs des sujets majeurs dont on
parlait juste avant quand on dit
l'écartier sensible l'accès aux services
publics dont la justice et est fortement
fortement entravée on a dit politique de
la ville mais en vérité c'est l'ensemble
des politiques qui dans ces quartiers
sont en recul santé
justice accès à la police aussi
évidemment donc
si s'il y a des pleins de points de
désaccord
parce que ça n'est pas qu'un projet de
budget pour la justice il n'empêche que
foncièrement le fait de pouvoir
rattraper notre retard il est colossal
en matière de juge par habitant ou par
100 000 habitants et c'est bien venu oui
alors en tout cas il y a une mesure dans
ce texte qui fait polémique cette mesure
elle permet d'activer à distance des
téléphones pour surveiller certains
suspects dans certaines enquêtes
notamment sur le crime organisé ou dans
des affaires de terrorisme est-ce que
selon vous c'est une atteinte aux
libertés oui oui je pense qu'il faut
pouvoir là encore sans esprit de
polémique
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
le Conseil de l'Europe pardon à
sanctionner la Russie
parce qu'elle avait activé la
reconnaissance faciale pour
identifier un manifestant Pacifique elle
a retrouvé dans le métro et évidemment
un État autoritaire a pu le sanctionner
je suis pas en train de dire que la
France et la Russie je dis juste que
nous sommes en train de valider là
c'était à l'occasion du projet de loi
Jeux Olympiques la reconnaissance
biométrique nous sommes en train de
valider des outils foncièrement
problématique si cette utilisé par un
gouvernement qui vous plaît tout va bien
si c'est tout utilisé par un
gouvernement qui ne vous plaît pas ou à
qui vous déplaisez alors il y a un
problème et voyez petit à petit nous
banalisons des procédures celles de
l'état d'urgence l'état d'urgence
sanitaire nous les faisons rentrer à
chausse-pied dans le droit commun et les
libertés reculent et moi ça m'inquiète
parce que la liberté de manifestation
est en recul aujourd'hui tout le monde
le sait tout le monde le comprend les
manifestations du 1er mai par exemple ne
sont plus aussi familiales qui a 15 ans
et ça n'est pas que de la faute des
manifestants la liberté d'associations
recule on a des maintenant des
dissolutions à répétitions quoi qu'on
pense des associations je pense qu'on
doit s'inquiéter quand le droit la
liberté d'association recule la lutte
anticorruption recule puisqu'il y a
agréable anticorps a perdu son agrément
je pense que oui tous ces éléments
doivent nous inquiéter et donc une série
de liberté qui recule sur le web allez
direction le Sénat puisque la commission
d'enquête de la Haute Assemblée sur
l'affaire du fond Marianne a rendu
conclusion jeudi elle dénonce la
responsabilité politique de la ministre
Marlène Schiappa dans la mauvaise
gestion de ce fonds gouvernemental qui
était censé lutter contre la
radicalisation en ligne les explications
de Samia déchir
dérive d'un coup politique opération de
communication les sénateurs n'ont pas de
mots assez dur pour qualifier l'échec du
fond Marianne le manque de rigueur
l'opacité et je le dis la désinvolture
on conduit au fiasco adopter à la quasi
unanimité le rapport de la commission
d'enquête est accablant pour Marlène
Schiappa en avril dernier six mois après
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty celle qui
est alors ministre en charge de la
citoyenneté lance un fond pour lutter
contre les discours séparatistes
2,5 millions d'euros attribués à 17
associations comment ont-elles été
choisie la commission d'enquête dénonce
la maturisme d'un processus de sélection
opaque ou la ministre serait
personnellement intervenu sans laisser
une trace écrite justifiant ses choix
initialement sélectionnés pour recevoir
100.000 euros SOS Racisme a finalement
été écartée du fond Marianne dans le cas
de SOS Racisme la ministre est intervenu
pour revenir sur une décision du comité
de sélection un mail daté du 1er juin
indique que la décision d'exclure cette
association a bien été prise lors d'une
réunion avec la ministre les sénateurs
reprochent aussi à Marlène Schiappa
d'avoir sélectionné une association
avant même la création du fond l'Union
des sociétés d'éducation physique et de
préparation militaire pour 355000 euros
l'USPPM codirigé par Mohamed cifaoui
n'aurait produit que quelques vidéos en
ligne sans que personne ne s'en est meuf
car une fois sélectionné les
associations n'auraient fait l'objet
d'aucun suivi pour contrôler leur action
s'étonne la commission d'enquête
senatoriale les échecs du fond Marianne
sont tout autant le résultat du des
investissements
du manque d'intérêt ou du désintérêt du
pouvoir politique
dès après la sélection des projets et
c'est un déni de responsabilité après
son lancement à l'exception d'une
réunion de décembre 2021 on ne peut
distinguer aucun signe d'une véritable
implication politique
quant à la mise en oeuvre de ce fond
Marianne la promesse qui avait été faite
solennellement devant les Français
à la suite d'un événement tragique n'a
pas été tenu
ce qui relève pleinement de la
responsabilité politique de la ministre
lors de son audition devant les
sénateurs Marlène Schiappa annie est
tout implication personnelle et ses
défaussée sur son administration un
témoignage contradictoire avec celui
d'autres acteurs entendus la commission
d'enquête a communiqué ses conclusions
au parquet national financier qui a déjà
ouvert une information judiciaire sur le
sujet
Julien Bayou le Sénat dénonce la
responsabilité politique de marine
chappa dans cette affaire du fond
Marianne et ce qu'elle peut actuellement
encore rester ministre en charge des
associations
c'est moche je sais pas comment vous
dire les les bons elle est complètement
décrédibilisée mais moi je ne l'aurais
pas nommé donc ça vous attendra pas si
je fais pas qu'elle reste au
gouvernement mais c'est bien plus grave
c'est à dire que les petits coups de
communication politique on en a vu
beaucoup
on peut même être blasé mais là on parle
de
une instrumentalisation du pire drame
qu'on est vu récemment l'assassinat
terroriste de Samuel Paty
au nom de la lutte contre la
radicalisation servir comme ça les
copains ou pouvoir attaquer des
opposants politiques enfin qu'est-ce que
c'est moche en fait c'est l'ensemble du
gouvernement qui est déshonoré si elle
est si elle continue donc vraiment je
moi j'ai un sentiment de dégoût et
pendant ce temps là qu'a-t-on fait sur
la contre la radicalisation vous voyez
c'est à dire qu'en fait tout inquiète
dans ce domaine comment elle a pu
continuer sous l'autorité de de son
ministre de tutelle d'armanin de la
première ministre et du président
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pour qu'ils
offrent comme ça des millions d'euros ou
des centaines de milliers d'euros qui
puissent écarter SOS Racisme alors
le monde associatif vous diriez qu'elle
a effectivement privilégié certaines
associations mais oui même si SOS
Racisme vous plaît
discriminations alors des fois
évidemment c'est pour pointer la
responsabilité de la police et il y en a
est-ce qu'il y a une part d'amaterisme
un fiasco administratif vous diriez quoi
vous auriez quelle vision j'espère qu'il
y aura des j'espère qu'il y aura des
suites judiciaires voilà
mais je voudrais pointer le fait contre
Marlène Schiappa contre ces personnes
qui finalement ont récupéré de l'argent
public pour pas de travail ou peu de
travail
on a parlé des métiers qui sont en
comparution immédiate qui ont pris du
ferme plusieurs mois ferme qui sont
aujourd'hui en prison avec mandat de
dépôt pour un pillage que je condamne
voyez le deux poids de mesure terrible
qu'il peut y avoir de la prison ferme
pour des très jeunes personnes des fois
17 des fois majeures mais sans casier
et là on parle finalement de possible
détournement d'argent public et puis en
fait pire parce que là c'est l'action
publique qui est dévoyé c'est pour moi
c'est infiniment pire si vous avez la
ministre d'associations au gouvernement
qui lance un grand plan contre la
rivière radicalisation et en fait pour
pouvoir
sortir du sort républicain ceci et les
écologistes c'était des islamsgistes
qu'est-ce qu'on a pas entendu et ceci
cela et en fait pour servir les copains
c'est infiniment pire et pourtant ça
risque d'être moins condamné je crois
vraiment qu'il y a un devoir de
d'exemplarité mais plus de hauteur de
retrouver la sérénité et là pour le coup
moi député
je salue le travail de la commission
d'enquête du Sénat pour le coup c'est
utile je vois on dit souvent le
Parlement l'assemblée c'est là c'est
pour voter non c'est aussi pour
contrôler l'action du gouvernement et là
le travail est bien fait le Parlement a
joué on va se quitter en rejetant un
petit coup d'oeil à l'agenda de avenir
au Parlement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et lundi les sénateurs entameront
l'examen du projet loi pour le plein
emploi ce texte qui prévoit notamment de
conditionner le versement du RSA à une
quinzaine d'heures d'activités ou de
formation par semaine mercredi à la
mission d'information du Sénat sur la
gestion durable de l'eau rendra son
rapport et ses conclusions pour mieux
préserver la ressource en eau face aux
épisodes de sécheresse récurrents à
l'Assemblée nationale mercredi 12
juillet Gérard Darmanin auditionné deux
fois devant la commission des lois puis
devant la commission d'enquête sur les
groupuscules violents et puis la loi de
programmation militaire qui sera aussi à
l'agenda mercredi avec du suspense on
verra si il y a un accord entre députés
sénateurs sur un texte commun Julien
Bayeux justement vous êtes vous siégé au
sein de la commission de la défense qui
va dont une partie des députés vont se
réunir avec sénateur pour tenter de
trouver un accord voilà je sais pas elle
fait partie de cette commission mix
paritaire on est très surpris que la
droite joue un petit peu le la course à
l'échalote avec le gouvernement sur la
question
la situation ne sont pas d'accord avec
le texte actuellement rédigé il ne
conteste pas les 413 milliards d'euros
de cette loi mais il en contestent la
calendrier le calendrier là je trouve
qu'il y a un peu d'hypocrisie parce
qu'en fait on les a senti très très
alignés tout du long et finalement là
c'est peut-être pour chatouiller le
gouvernement peut-être avant les
sénatoriales faire échouer la commission
mix paritaire écouter si elle revient à
l'Assemblée moi j'en serais heureux
parce que c'est vrai que cette loi de
programmation militaire nous engage pour
des décennies décider d'un nouveau
porte-avion de de ou de de solidarité
européenne dans la construction dans
l'armement de la défense de la sécurité
ce sont pas des choix qui doivent être
fait au hasard et si nous avons
l'occasion d'y porter à nouveau des
amendements à nouveau des propositions
pour renforcer la sécurité européenne
commune je m'en réjouis et bien ce sera
le mot de la fin Julien Bayou merci
beaucoup d'avoir été le dernier invité
de cette saison puisque la saison se
termine mais on se retrouve à la saison
prochaine et merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis cette année merci à toutes les
équipes de Parlement Hebdo d'avoir rendu
possible cette émission cette année
[Musique]